Hi guys, we are back with more in Missionary Zero.
We're here to save the moon!
The moon!
Yeah!
So like, if you guys can tell, we're all white except for mint.
I didn't get the memo.
At least this time we all have our spacesuits on.
We all... Okay, we're looking at everybody's screens.
Yeah, yeah, we all have our own little spaces this time.
Yeah, thank you for letting us rent them out.
No, thanks to the artists that I found.
Oh, I'm glad.
Yeah, mint's the main character now.
It's me!
The reason why we were a little late is because I actually made a public lobby.
Wraith, are you watching?
Are you watching this?
I'm sorry if we didn't give you a warm welcome.
We were like, get out!
Who are you?
Leave!
I feel bad if they aren't our viewer and then they joined and we were all just like, who is that?
I know.
We were all just yelling at him.
We were all screaming at him.
Did he hear you guys?
He never said hi.
Yeah.
Yeah, we don't all.
Yeah, he never said hi to us too.
We were all like, I'll be too fair.
It was like, we're women screaming at him.
I know, just be like, what is this?
Who are you?
He's like, get out of here!
And I'm like, wait, I can kick him, guys.
But, um, it was actually really funny because like, when we were all getting together for the stream, um, Min and Nimi were like, I don't remember how I played a game.
No.
But then the thing is, on the other side, the yellow women, you being at, we were making a plan.
We're making a plan!
We got the greens?
Yeah, we were making a plan.
We're gonna be carried today.
We wrote notes down.
Yeah, we wrote notes.
We're reliable people, right, dude?
Uh-huh.
Yeah, us yellow women, we know what to do.
What?!
We worked out in our brains.
Yeah, we worked it out.
What is this?
What do you guys bring to the table, huh?
Yeah, what are you guys doing?
I bring the colors!
I bring the...
I do the cooking!
I do the cleaning!
Okay.
What about you, Mimi?
What's your job?
I'm quite... I'm just quite... I'm prepared.
I forgot my homework at home.
What were we doing?
I don't remember... Okay, so... So, remember this area where there was that man that kept killing us?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, we're gonna skip that for now.
We're gonna do the easier task.
Okay.
So... Okay.
Um, the thing is...
Um, the... the trees with orange leaves, that one... Yeah.
Um, we dug up two of those.
But what happened to those items?
I don't know.
Oh, I don't know.
Oh, yeah.
We don't have any items.
I guess we gotta get them again.
No!
Because I already see one tree... yellow... orange tree in front of me.
But it says two out of five on the objectives.
Yeah, but we need to put the items in the yellow car.
Oh!
What if it's a bug?
What if we lost them?
Oh, I don't know.
Maybe... maybe it's in that... maybe it's in the... the... the vending machine or whatever.
Oh, it could be!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go to the vending machine, please.
How do we... Okay, hold on.
I need to... What's the controls again for this game?
Wow!
I think there's a vending machine over here.
Oh!
Alright.
Let me know if the audio's okay, guys.
This game... it's so hard.
Oh!
Oh, they're right here!
Yeah!
Okay.
So, the thing about it is that...
It's just one yellow car.
I don't remember where the... I don't know where the yellow car is, but I know where all the trees are.
Well, I don't know where all the trees are, but... I know where some of the trees are.
We gotta explore for the trees.
Yeah.
Okay.
So...
So, someone has to carry the other two items.
Okay, everyone.
I got one.
Alright, let's go.
I'll watch.
Who is breathing?
Yeah.
Okay, so... Who is breathing?
We got this tree.
I think it's those cats.
Yeah, I think it's the cats.
Oh, there's also a tree over here on this side for sure.
We didn't dig that one, right?
I'm not sure, but there's like...
Watch out.
Don't die like Doki did last time.
Alright.
Dig.
I'll carry this one.
Dig!
Alright.
Yay!
Okay, so we need to find the yellow car for this.
Oh, I found another one!
Oh my god, the cat's here.
Oh, wait, that thing's dead.
That's a cat?
Why are we suddenly calling it a cat?
Oh my god.
Wait, how do you... Oh, crouch is this.
Wait, where is everybody?
Hello?
Wait, how'd they die?
Did they die?
Hello?
Oh shoot, are they dead?
No way.
Did everybody die?
No, no, no.
It wouldn't be... Oh, there they are.
I was gonna say, it wouldn't be jumping all around like that then.
If they were dead.
I hear them.
Is this a yellow car?
No.
Failed to save the game.
Oh!
I'm here!
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Oh shoot.
Wait, I think they're possessed.
Ah!
Wait!
We just started the game.
I'm too...
Ah!
Wait, wait, wait!
We just started the game, please!
Please!
Why?
We just started the game!
I'll go a circle.
I'm looping him.
Here.
Okay.
You're our hero!
See, that's why you're the main character!
I'm the main character!
I thought you were... We all thought you were dead!
No, I was just by myself!
I was scared!
I was literally trying... We were literally trying to revive you!
Let me over here!
We gotta find the yellow car... There's a thing all the way over there, be careful!
Okay... Oh wait... Oh, what the hell is that?
What is that?
Oh wait, the yellow car is over here!
It's on the other side of the hill!
Oh!
Okay, okay... Wait, what's he saying?
Oh, he wants the orange!
Wait, should we help him?
Yeah, we should!
We should!
Yeah!
Never mind... Wait, yellow woman can't see yellow?
We died!
It looked yellowish!
This guy wants the orange, finally!
Yeah, we should help him!
Take the orange!
I don't remember where it was!
I don't remember, too!
Yeah, probably!
I wanted to find this... Goddamn yellow car!
It has to be, like, outside here!
Maybe it's inside in the... In here?
In the middle?
Oh, there's an orb over there!
Oh!
Oh, yeah!
It's right where we lived!
There was a guy over here!
So we should be careful!
Yeah!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah!
No, I remember!
I... I definitely remember!
Maybe it's on this side!
I'm gonna check this side!
Like, cause we didn't go to... We didn't explore this area too much!
Did we explore this... Did we explore all of this side?
I don't think so!
I think you guys got... This is, like, the part that loops around, isn't it?
There's probably down here, right?
Yeah, this was the car with... There's so many cars!
Surely one of them is yellow!
Yellow car!
Yeah, this is a dead end!
No, it's a dead end!
Oh, no!
Please!
What did we do all the way back to the beginning?
There's no way!
No!
I thought you took notes!
Wait, is our car yellow?
I took notes!
Uh-oh!
There's the guy!
There's the jumpy guy!
Okay!
Oh, there's the jumpy!
Yay!
I'm gonna go for it!
Yeah!
Holy cow!
Oh my god.
Okay, here we go.
We went left, right?
Okay, let's go right.
There has to be one yellow car.
Maybe it's with all these guys in here.
Yeah, it could be over here.
Oh, that's true.
Aren't we missing someone?
I don't know, there's no cars over here.
Oh my god.
Are we?
Mimi?
Wait, where's your other green one?
Green woman.
Green lost.
Green woman lost.
Hold on.
I thought I just saw her over here.
Maybe she split up.
Split up, gang.
All right.
Wait, where's Doobie?
Where's the other yellow woman?
Oh my god, that's scary.
Oh, okay.
There, let's see.
Hello.
Oh, hello.
I dropped the battery somewhere.
Oh.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
We'll find her.
Oh, I see her.
Okay, okay.
Is it over here?
Dookie's got it, yeah.
I got it, I got it.
Oh, thank you, thank you.
So we gotta go...
We gotta go... Uh... Wait, where's my shovel?
Is it... You can have multiple items in your inventory, right?
Wait.
What happened to my shovel?
It's back there.
Oh!
Can you not?
Oh, don't.
Okay, I got my... Wait.
Wait, I can't... Oh, no.
I can't carry the shovel because it's too heavy.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, where did Doobie go?
Doobie?
Should we... Should we... Save?
She should be fine, right?
Right?
I'm sure she's just looking for the yellow car, right?
Yeah.
Right.
The goddamn delusive yellow car.
I don't think it's out here.
I think it might be somewhere else.
I mean, right here is the other guy.
Yeah.
Oh my god, okay.
I can't be there.
I thought it was, like, closer.
We haven't found it.
Doobie did something.
What?
What did Doobie do?
Wait, how do you know Doobie did something?
Is our task updated?
Oh!
Doobie doobie do.
Yeah.
Doobie do.
Where are you?
What did Doobie doobie.
Oh!
Wait, is that yellow car?
Do you see a car up there?
There's a yellow car?
Oh, I see it all the way in the back.
Is that yellow?
Are you kidding me?
It looks yellow, yeah.
Is that yellow?
He's coming towards us.
He is, he is.
Okay.
All right.
Ah, he's following you.
He's following you.
Wait.
He's following you, Nimi.
Yellow woman down?
Uh-oh.
Do you think she's got it?
Oh gosh, I'm just gonna run for it.
But it's so loud, it's scary.
Someone was down!
It's the yellow car.
Margaret's edge over there...
wait, it said,
oh here...
Oh my God, oh my God, oh my God, oh my God, oh my God, oh my God, please no!
please God...
Okay, we're finally started.
I think we lost Nimi.
Hello.
Welcome back.
You're a doobie.
I couldn't tell because you were all white.
I dropped the battery near the yellow car, though.
Oh, okay.
It's on the back of the car.
You have to, like, yeah.
I put mine in.
I'll take doobie to it.
I found a map of all the batteries and where the car is.
It's over there, though.
We can go afterwards.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, yeah, nice, nice.
So, we just need to find... We just have, like, two more batteries.
And then... Because that unlocks one of the electrical boards.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This area is so scary.
I told you I took it.
Run through the building.
Or... Yeah.
I'm gonna freaking die.
Don't freaking die.
Don't do it.
It's on the back.
Right click, right click.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
Where did I drop it?
I got it.
Okay, keep going straight.
And there's a map over here.
This way.
If we go this way.
Where's the other battery?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, okay.
Wait, where am I now?
I don't know.
They say certain items are buried in... Oh, yeah.
The trees.
I was following doobie and then I lost her.
Yeah?
Hello.
Oh, they're all over there.
I was a scaredy cat and I ran back inside.
Okay, I'll run too.
We're running in solidarity as a team.
We're running as a team.
Oh, we're trying to... There's one more here.
Oh my god, these are so scary.
Oh my gosh, these are so scary.
I'm here!
Oh, keep going, keep going, keep going, keep going.
Okay, time!
Oh, save, save, save, save, save.
What is that?
Okay.
I'm so jumpy today.
Holy cow.
There's a map here.
I don't know which one we got.
Yeah, it's kind of hard to tell.
I think we just need the one right here that you passed, no?
No, no.
We need one more.
So two more.
I think...
Two, four... No, yeah.
So it has to be on the other side.
Where all the other trees were.
Wait, did we save?
Yeah, we did.
Yeah.
Wait, what happened to the... Did you guys pick up the other battery?
No.
Which... Which other battery?
The one that just dug up.
It's like over there.
Oh, yeah.
That's what I was saying.
I think... Is that not the last one that we need?
No, no.
It's three out of five.
Oh, oh.
You're right.
It totally says that right there.
You know, it's just numbers.
I can't count.
Does your strategy guide include the code for that safe in there?
I don't have any chance.
I don't.
You went to the yellow car.
Oh, I'm trapped.
I'm gonna see if I can find that.
Wait, I see a tree over... No, maybe it's just a street light.
Maybe.
I'll go over.
I'll check it.
Doesn't hurt.
Wait, how do we get out?
Oh, yeah.
There's a door.
Wow, thanks.
Thanks, Doki Bird.
Your wisdom is... Is infinite.
What?
I'm almost positive we've gotten this.
Yeah.
Yeah, we... Yeah, but some of the... It says, like, some of them... Do we get out?
Yeah, wait.
I'll give you guys the battery and I'll go back to the map and check it again.
Okay.
There might be one over here.
Watch out for the hand.
It's okay.
You can't reach me.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, you're right.
He's stuck.
Trapped.
Doesn't hurt.
Okay.
This is a dead end.
I thought I could get to the other side.
Oh.
Wait, I can.
What is that?
Yeah.
Shortcut?
What is that?
What's it shaking for?
What's shaking?
Bacon?
Freeze.
Oh, this is where we're at.
Where everybody died at the library.
Oh.
The underground.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I remember.
Oh, it says, like, a shortcut.
Oh, yeah.
You have to go back to the yellow car.
Do you think you can do it?
Wait, wait.
There's a guy right inside.
No?
I just saw him walk.
Oh, it's the... It's the orange things.
The orange glows.
Oh, yeah.
Who's back here?
Orange glows?
Uh, coven.
Oh, the coven guys.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Oh,
maybe we... Oh, yeah.
See, there's the library.
Okay.
I was like...
I think I know where we are.
This is for me?
That's really kind of you.
With your help, I think we might finally manage the head replacement.
I've heard there's a people past in the basement that leads straight into the laboratory.
I think we're okay.
See you in the basement, and check your map.
There's a hidden way into the basement outside of the main building.
Oh?
Oh, what?
Oh.
Oh, there's God.
I didn't really process what he meant by that.
There's a secret way to that basement.
Outside the main building.
Yeah, where are we going?
Um... We're literally missing one tree.
One tree.
You got this one?
We must have found this one.
Watch out, the eyeball.
It was dug.
Yeah, see, like, this is dug up.
We got this one.
Was there another one?
There was another one on the other side, we got that one.
Yeah, that's three.
So we're... Do you think... Here, hold on, let's save right here just in case... Well, Doobie should be alive, right?
Right?
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Doobie's alive.
So maybe to the right?
Watch out, watch out!
Watch out!
He's coming!
Oh, no!
Three, four, five.
That's the fifth tree!
We had to have gotten this though.
Apparently we got this one.
Yeah.
But I counted five.
What?
What happened to the last battery?
Do you think it's missing somewhere?
Maybe we dropped it when somebody died and we don't realize?
Oh, no.
Did we respawn it somewhere?
That's not a good thing.
Was it inside this building when we spawned?
Oh, no.
Oh, gosh.
There's a guy right there.
Oh, nice.
The thing is, Doobie, we found all the trees, but...
Those trees have been dug up.
Could we have counted one tree twice?
Did we count one tree twice?
Maybe.
Okay.
Far right.
One.
Two.
I think it's, like, all the way to the right.
Like, all the way.
Okay.
All the way down this way.
Wait, actually, wait.
Green women.
Yeah.
Put the battery in.
Oh, okay.
One of the guys should learn.
All right.
One of the women will find the last tree.
All right, Nimmy, let's go.
Wait, we're here, right?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, it's over here.
It's easier, I think, to go inside the building, so...
Okay.
We'll just run.
I believe in the power of green.
Run in here!
Ah!
Keep going!
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run!
Okay!
Go, go, go!
Ah!
I'm looking for any batteries, just in case.
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna bring him to that...
No!
We did it!
The green women did it!
We're still trying to find the orange tree.
We're still trying to find...
You counted how many?
I don't know.
You don't?
What do you mean you don't?
You have one job!
What do you mean you don't know?
Ooh, an egg!
Ooh!
Ooh, egg!
We dug that tree over there.
Green.
Yeah, we did do this one!
Yeah.
Hmm.
I didn't see any while we were on that side, either.
I feel like my eyes were just glued to the jumping point.
I don't!
Uh-oh.
I think they're getting chased.
Oh, my God.
Who's...
Did the thing just jump in here?
Oh...
He's right behind me, isn't he, guys?
Oh.
Oh, my God!
His head extends!
His head...
Oh, I don't like that.
He can't come in here.
No, I don't think so.
Wait.
Okay, so...
We got...
Oh.
Hi.
Hello.
Yeah, what does the bloom mean?
That's where we are.
We got the one...
We got the tree to the left side.
So we need to get...
These three.
This is a confusing map.
What?
It makes no sense.
Huh?
Doobie even took a photo of it.
The real...
This is the real horror.
Reading a map.
Who is that out there?
Silent Hill 2.
That's Doobie.
Oh, Doobie.
Doobie?
Blair witching out here.
Yes.
I'm gonna say.
Hello, I'm fixing something.
Oh, sure.
I'm fixing something on us.
You're good, you're good.
Okay, don't worry.
We'll protect you, Doobie.
Hi.
What's up?
Did you guys find it?
No.
We got this.
Look, it's on the other side.
That's the thing.
I think we had it.
Maybe somebody dropped it.
This...
Uh oh.
Okay.
I don't wanna deal with it.
What if we dropped it in that...
This thing scares me!
What if we dropped it in that one building with the guy with the sword?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, you might have a point there.
We'll find it.
I think...
Maybe it's safe?
No.
Is it safe?
Kind of.
Okay.
Where'd they go anyways?
The...
Where'd they go?
I don't know actually.
We could go check the sword building.
Oh, you wanna stay here?
No, no, no.
I got stuck on the...
Oh.
On the map.
That happened to me earlier.
Oh.
Oh, there they are.
I see someone.
Yeah, let's check in the building.
Let's see.
I think so, yeah.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Someone said that...
We only have dug four out of five.
It says it on our task list.
Yeah, okay.
And then...
Four is over here.
Oh yeah, yeah.
This one's dug up too.
Four.
Then there's one by the truck.
We did not dig here!
Oh.
We did though!
I think it reset because we definitely did before.
Mint picked this up.
Why me?
It's your fault.
It's me!
It's my fault?
Okay.
That's fine.
I'm just kidding.
It's always the main character's fault.
It's the main character.
Okay, I'm the main character.
I'll put this in.
Do
we have to like start the car or something?
Or is it just gonna unlock?
Oh no.
It opens the electrical board.
I'm gonna watch.
Oh my god.
There's so...
I did it!
Oh it opened!
Oh my god.
I'm gonna die?
Oh god.
Oh god!
Is this...
Okay.
I don't know actually where they can go in and where they can't.
Okay!
I'm alive!
Somehow!
I don't like the way they breathe.
I don't know what was inside though.
I didn't get it.
Red electrical box.
The red electrical box.
I just hear them breathing.
I'm the main character!
I'm so sorry guys that the monsters are so loud.
It's because Nimi is kind of quiet.
And so I have it kind of way turned up.
So...
If you can't...
You can't adjust people individually.
So...
If we get spooked, we get spooked together!
It's scarier.
Yeah.
Hearing Nimi is important.
I agree.
I would rather hear Nimi than...
Anything else.
More immersive!
Okay.
I'm gonna run over there to them.
I just wanna explain that real quick for you guys.
Okay, run.
Oh wait.
I think I see this.
One of them.
What happens to the other?
What was in the trunk?
Did you get it?
No.
That was your job.
Oh no.
There was a guy right there.
My job was to put in the thing.
Wait.
Then what happened to Nimi?
Uh oh.
Um...
She...
Should we go to the safe point at the cross?
That's why there were two of you.
One to grab the item and the other to...
No, there was a guy right behind me.
He was blocking the...
The...
The trunk.
We have to go this way.
Oh yeah!
That trunk.
All that junk.
Junk in that trunk.
Okay, we got...
Oh wait.
There's a safe point here, right?
Yeah.
Oh is there?
Alright Nimi.
What's it meant to do to you?
Get you drunk.
Get you love drunk.
You guys have to grab the...
The electrical board.
Yeah, where's the electrical box?
It's in the back of the trunk.
We gotta go get...
Oh...
Oh my god.
Go, go, go!
I see it.
They can't stop all of us.
They could.
They can.
They could, yeah.
Oh my god.
We got it.
Yay!
We got to get to the lab.
Wait, no.
Oh my god.
He's here?
Oh, wait.
How do we get to the lab?
I thought it was this way.
It was the other one.
It was the...
Other one?
Remember when we had to go to like...
Yellow women?
What...
What was the plan here?
Look, yellow women had a little like...
There's a little snafu with the yellow women.
Okay.
We had a lot of plans.
We just brought up the wrong plan.
Yeah.
Okay.
We're following you now.
Plan B.
Now we're going to do plan C.
What...
What was plan A?
My shift key doesn't work.
Do that!
Oh shoot.
Um, we just lost somebody.
Can
we do plan D?
Can we do plan D?
This is all part of plan C.
Plan D for Doki and Doki.
There you go.
See?
Plan C.
All according to plan.
How cool.
That's not this way.
That's not the plan part.
Slenderman's in there.
Yeah, but this is where we went to the lab.
Remember?
Are you running?
Okay, you're good?
I think so.
Okay.
Yeah, it was this one, right?
Or was it the other side?
Oh, no.
Here.
I don't remember what the objective was.
I don't remember.
Wait, I remember.
We have to go...
We have to go to the basement.
Remember?
And then take another elevator.
Guys, maybe we shouldn't have waited two weeks to do a part two.
Wait, the objectives...
Wait, did we do the safe box on the second floor annex?
Wait, it's all coming back to me.
The safe box?
Oh my...
I'm dead.
I just... I just accepted my fate.
Where did he come from?
It was like in the elevator.
I wasn't...
Yeah, it was the elevator.
It was like... down here?
That was so...
Oh yeah, it was down here.
Yeah, I trust you.
Yellow woman with the plan.
Exactly, I have a plan.
Does she?
Does she now?
Where's she?
It's so dark in here.
Here you go.
Hi!
Alright, and then we take this elevator.
I'm trying to press the elevator button.
My item is blind.
Okay.
And then...
We go to basement two.
And then we go to another elevator.
And then we go down.
I...
You're saying a lot of shit right now.
Makes sense to me.
I get it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You just gotta...
Okay, the thing is...
I...
I don't remember which...
It was this way, right?
Which way?
We don't know where you're trying to go.
I don't think it was this way.
There's a guy!
Oh my god!
Wait.
Wait, I'm...
Give me a sec.
Wasn't it the main elevator and then you select like a different floor?
No, no, no.
Because we had to take two elevators.
So like, it was from here.
Now we went to a different...
Oh, I remember!
You have said, I remember like five times.
Review the VOD.
Remember when we had to run past the other guy?
This wouldn't have happened if Raze was here.
Yeah.
Oh, she do be remembered.
My fellow yellow woman remembered.
We have to run past this guy.
There's a guy over here, by the way.
So be careful.
I don't think we run that way, but...
He'll get us immediately.
Is it this way?
He's right there.
Oh?
No, it was this way.
He here?
Yeah, he's coming.
Maybe not.
Is it that way?
Uh-oh.
I don't know who died?
How do I get over there?
I'm lost!
It was probably Doobie.
I'm scared though.
I'm scared.
Guys, I'm all by myself!
Wait, I think I have to go though, no?
Because they need me for the elevator?
Hey, do I need to come over there?
I hear them.
If I die...
I'm dead.
I lived!
Holy moly!
I'm the main character!
I hear them.
Do I need to come over there?
Can they hear me?
Alright, we opened the hatch.
They opened the hatch.
Just running for it.
You think the move was made out of you, you know?
Oh!
Uh...
Hello?
Oh!
Oh, man!
Hi!
Yeah, I'm...
Doobie's dead.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
See, you followed the wrong yellow woman.
I told you I had a plan.
Is there...
There's no loyalty here?
No, okay.
The yellow car plan was my plan.
She's in charge of the other plan.
So...
What was the other plan?
The other plan was the...
You didn't even know where the yellow car was.
I found...
What do you mean?
I was a hero!
For the record, I've had survivor's guilt this whole time.
And I feel...
No, she did.
She forgot about you.
For the record, I could always hear your voice in my head.
Yeah, I was talking.
I could hear you guys, too.
Okay, we gotta...
We gotta go revive the other yellow woman because she actually has the...
She has the part two of this plan.
Oh, okay.
Wait, what did you guys do down there?
Oh, we opened the hatch for the moon.
The moon!
Yeah, yeah.
We just need to open the second hatch, but...
Okay, we gotta get out of here first.
The second yellow woman has part two.
Okay.
I was only part one.
I don't wanna die.
It's too loud.
How did she die?
The guy got her.
So we should avoid that.
And where is this guy?
Mr. Slenderman?
And where is this guy you speak of?
We could just jump, right?
Oh, no.
I won't let us...
No, I don't...
No, we have to go through...
The guy.
So...
Ladies first.
I think if you just run for it...
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
There he is!
He'll only get one of us.
Wrong elevator!
He can't come in here, I think.
There we go.
What the heck?
I can still hear you!
He can't even come in here!
No, I was waiting for you guys.
With the door closed?
Yeah, for safety.
Like when you see someone coming down the hall...
...and then yell at me and hit the door close button.
Safe!
I'm just trying to save energy.
Hey!
Welcome back!
Doobie, you're here for part two.
Part two of the plan.
Alright, but if you guys make fun of me, I'm not doing the plan.
No, no, I was saying...
I heard you!
Yeah!
No, I was saying that...
I was...
Um...
What do we do?
Oh, shoot.
Oh...
He can't come in here!
No, please no!
No, no, no, no!
No, no, no!
That wasn't me!
Why?
Who was it?
Who said?
That was my revenge.
It might have been deserved.
Honestly.
I was like, you can't come over here!
How do we get back to like the annex anyways?
It's the...
We gotta go outside, though.
We gotta go up.
Yeah.
We gotta go outside.
Watch out for him.
He's a sneaky one, that guy.
We'll just...
Yeah, that was very...
Oh!
Keep going!
Oh, shoot.
This is a dead end.
Oh, wait.
No, it's not.
Um...
Okay, cool.
Oh!
Was it Doobie?
Somebody's at the same point.
Well, she should come to our save point.
Yeah.
She should come to our save point.
We're the ones here.
Maybe we don't go up these stairs.
Maybe we...
We
won.
Yeah, it's 2v1.
We can win.
We'll just wait until she's dead.
Yeah.
I don't actually even know where she is.
It might be a while.
I don't know.
Did she go outside?
I think she went this way.
Yeah.
Upstairs?
Wait, where'd you go?
Oh, I was down here.
Maybe...
Yeah, maybe over here.
Can we go outside this way?
Yeah.
I think there's like the front door around here.
Oh.
Right here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um...
Wait, how do we get around?
Where is she?
You think she's at the other save point?
The one outside that we started at?
Oh!
Maybe.
Wait, oh, but this is a dead end.
We can't get over here.
I think we have to go through the building.
Oh.
Okay.
Um...
Can we open this?
I'm gonna see if this opens.
Oh, good.
Yeah.
Oh.
Is it a shortcut?
No, but it's good to have...
Oh, there's the inky guy.
Little ink blob guy.
Oh, gosh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, I see her.
I see her.
Don't worry.
I know where to go.
I was waiting for you guys.
Okay.
We need doobie though.
We need doobie.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a safe station right here.
Okay.
Yeah.
Part two of Plan C.
Okay.
All right.
All right, doobie.
Hi.
You're trying to shine.
Follow me.
Oh, we're going back in here?
Oh, no.
She had to research part two.
And I was...
Oh, I hear him.
I hear him.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'll...
I'll meet them.
Wait, I think the stairs are through that room.
Okay.
I think I don't know.
Oh.
It's squishy in here.
Oh,
the stairs I think are over...
Right here.
Okay, wait.
Hold on.
Let me check something.
Dad, I lost him.
You lost him?
I can't see anything.
Oh gosh.
Hello.
I don't know.
Oh, hey.
Hey, I'm looking for the room that has all the canisters down here that we did when we first...
Did this?
Oh, the room with green lines.
Oh.
I...
I didn't research that part.
I left it to you.
No, no, no, no.
It's already the part that we did.
It's just I need to find it.
Okay.
Isn't it too...
Isn't it up there...
To the right and then left?
Upstairs?
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
You found it?
Are we alive though?
Yeah.
I lost everybody?
How?
Why am I always lost?
She's dead.
Who's dead?
Um...
She's dead.
Oh shoot.
I can't see!
You're alive.
Hello!
Hi!
I think...
I think we lost one, but...
Yeah, I think we lost...
Oh, I just gotta find the room again.
I think it was...
Oh, it was...
Yeah, through here and then over here.
Oh gosh, I'm trapped.
Oh, who just died?
I'm dead.
I think I'm dead.
Look at them hips.
Damn, girl.
I'm here!
Hi.
He just walked that way.
Oh, are you just been hiding here?
The entire time?
Not the entire time.
I just hid here now.
Why'd you shut the door?
So I'm trying to put...
Okay, I think Mimi and Doobie are dead.
So we have to go back.
Okay.
Fine by me.
Get me out of here.
I'm pretty sure they're dead.
I think so too.
Hello!
I pushed it a little bit.
I know where it's to move from.
I think there's a way to go upstairs.
It's like right by the room.
Uh...
Yeah, it's
just...
Oh, is he over there?
I don't know.
It's right here.
We're gonna be pushed upstairs.
Oh.
He's here, he's here, he's here!
He's fencing.
He's fencing?
Yeah.
Oh my god!
He was taken off!
We're distracting him?
Kinda?
We lost him?
He's around here somewhere.
Yeah.
Where is he?
Oh!
Nimi's got him!
Okay.
Nimi, you got him?
Nimi is...
Alive.
Probably.
Is he alive?
Yeah, I hear.
I hear.
What can I do?
I'm just standing here.
I'm here?
I'm...
I think it's already upstairs.
I got one of them upstairs.
Okay.
I'm pushing, I'm pushing.
But I don't know where to go after that.
Oh.
Pull.
Okay.
Is that all of them?
Nope, there's no pull.
There we go.
Oh, it does.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
What happened to the other one?
Okay, wait, wait.
Let's see him.
Nimi is...
Hey!
What the hell?
Wait, let's see if Nimi died or not.
Cause I don't think she's alive.
What?
Are we gonna save?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I think it'd be good too.
Yeah, I have to leave you instead.
Wee!
Alright.
Follow Nimi.
Her sacrifice is not in vain.
Alright, so...
What I...
Realize...
It like pushes the monster away.
Oh!
Hopefully that guy doesn't come up here, and then we just push these into the right spot.
I think he will though.
I don't know if he goes...
He might go backwards though, so...
Watch out behind you.
Oh, you might like change direction?
Yeah.
I think he...
Probably does.
I'm scared.
Me too!
This is scary!
We should get...
Somebody should get in between the canisters and then...
Yeah, yeah, I'm in between.
We actually need to be in for it and I'll be back.
Cause...
Cause you know where to go.
Oh, he's coming!
He's coming!
Oh...
Oh God!
Oh shoot!
Oh gosh.
I went the wrong...
Oh, no.
I'm good.
This way?
Oh shoot.
I can't see anything here.
Wait.
This way is the safe point!
This way, this way.
Yeah, yeah.
We're back.
Okay, it only works in the hallway, I guess.
Okay.
We'll wait for him to pass.
Then we'll go back.
Okay.
Like for that guy.
I hear him.
Someone has to bait him out of here.
This guy sucks.
I saw him run fastest!
Let's go and let somebody lead him away.
I'm probably not meeting him.
Go!
Someone, I need to push this.
He's here!
I'm trapped?
Oh, it's okay.
He's trapped too.
Wait.
Oh, no it's not!
Wyrm, Wyrm!
Oh my god, I think two people just got got.
Yep, it's all Doobie.
It's all Doobie!
Sure looks like Team Green is carrying.
My throat is hurting a little bit today.
Maybe I overdid it yesterday.
I'm gonna take some...
Okay.
Sign.
Throat.
Syrup.
Alright, round two!
Just kidding.
Round two!
Okay.
One of the canisters is in there.
Yay!
Okay.
I'm pushing it with you.
Push, push, push, push.
I see a red line, yeah, over here.
I'll go for that one.
Is it...
Over here in this corner.
Oh, over here, over here.
There's one over here too.
There's one more over here.
Oh, go this way?
This way.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, I see it.
Yeah, there he is.
See, we got it.
Ay!
So now there's just one more.
Last one's here, last one's here!
Yo, yo, yo, you!
I believe.
If you can crawl under here!
Yahoo!
Woo-hoo!
Alright, let's go save before.
We won, we won.
Yeah, let's go save.
Go save!
I've got the dynamite.
You can go this way.
Follow.
Don't go this way!
Don't go that way.
Don't go that way!
Is it this way?
Yeah, I did it this way.
Baby.
Is this the dynamite?
No.
This is the dynamite.
I can place it now.
I can place it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
Maybe there's a save point over there.
Nice, nice, nice.
There's got to be a save point here.
Yeah, there has to be a save point right here, right?
What's all that?
Oh, yeah, yeah, there we go.
Ew.
It's... No, it's... It's COVID.
Okay, Mimi's still alive.
What's that sound?
Oh.
Because we all saw Mint die, so...
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yes.
This stuff doesn't kill us?
No, no.
It's weird.
Hello.
I'm about to be revived.
Revive me.
A new area.
Yeah.
I don't know what to do past here, but we'll figure it out.
I... Remembers.
Oh.
Whoa.
It's your wife, Mint.
But she's... Oh my god.
Stranger lady.
She's here.
Yeah.
Read us the dialogue.
You actually made it.
That horned beast had it out for you.
A real nasty piece of work.
And don't even get me started on that worm.
Any worm.
Yeah, what a worm.
Good job not dying.
Yeah, we totally didn't die.
Zero deaths, guys.
Oh, that's all.
Oh.
Oh, really?
Zero deaths.
Not very informative.
Alright, that was my plan, and uh, that's all I got.
We have a, we have a, what's it called?
Wait, he has no head.
Oh.
Oh, wait, I think we can put something here now.
Is that the alien from the, the, you know, the Mexico alien?
Yeah.
Yeah, the, oh.
I bet if we swap the other TV guy's head with an orange.
What does this do?
Oh, the second floor.
Yeah, we can do it.
Oh.
I turned it on.
TV head with no head.
No head.
There's another guy.
There's two of them.
Two of them, two of them, two of them, two of them.
There's two TV heads with no head.
Not working.
This is that one area with a guy that's in the circle.
So this is, this area is the new area.
I wonder if we have to take the canisters from up there down here.
Probably.
I haven't fully explored this area though.
We can fly a TV with no head.
Yeah, there's two of them.
Oh.
Yeah, I think this is where we came from.
Oh, the lights.
Can we go to the, is there another area here?
Close on the other side.
The beach, we're not right.
Do we explore everything?
If we only get us one area, we didn't.
Oh, what the heck?
Oh, come on.
Why?
Maybe because we opened one of those doors.
Oh.
I hear him breathing.
All right.
Oh, no.
Come back.
Do we explore everything in, in this area?
I feel like there's something we missed.
Yeah, then we missed an area.
I'm pretty sure.
Or the second floor?
Is this the second floor?
Can we go this way?
The second floor?
No, we didn't go this way, guys.
Oh, yeah.
Over here.
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
The worms scared me.
Oh, okay.
Nothing here.
It's just an empty room.
There's so many rooms here.
Oh, this is a, oh, this is a circle.
This is a circle.
Oh, we opened.
Oh, yeah.
We need the gun.
Oh, oh, we gotta go.
Oh, wait, isn't that other area that opened up?
Yeah, we go straight to the third floor and grab the gun.
Maybe we should save that one.
Yeah, yeah.
Save it?
Okay.
What, there's a, there's a gun on the third floor?
The vending machine?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
See, we're sinking with portals now.
Why is this guy here, though?
I'm scared of him.
I think he, like, came from...
Where did he go?
Yeah.
Oh, we're here.
Okay, okay.
Oh, it's a big ol' loot.
Yeah, um, you get the gun and I'll grab the lamp.
Okay.
All right.
Don't worry, I'll light our paths now.
We got this, guys.
We're gonna save the moon.
We need our tidal wave.
To the other side.
This way.
Yeah, all the way to the end.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, don't worry.
I'm lining the path.
I got that spear.
What?
I thought someone just died right behind.
It was so dark.
Oh my god.
Oh, this.
Wait, there's a little hole here.
Go in there.
I go in this little hole.
A man?
Oh, there's more stairs here.
It's over on this side.
Yeah.
Orange heads cannot hear.
Oh.
What's an orange head?
It's the...
It's the orbs.
The COVID orbs.
Oh.
Wait, why is...
Why is that guy here?
Oh, there's a TV here.
I found a TV.
Oh, put it on his head.
Put it on his head.
Yeah, we gotta go find...
Where is he?
Um...
He's on the bottom floor.
I mean, the next floor.
This way, this way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You lead the way.
We can...
Okay, watch out.
We can go for him.
Over here.
Yeah, yeah, there he is.
Here's one.
He's alive!
We did it.
Oh, he's sad.
Be happy.
Yeah.
Oh.
Excuse me.
You said, oh.
Hey.
Hey, hi.
It seems you're not infected.
The little black liquid creatures didn't catch you.
But I remember the times before the moon was brought here.
Back then, there were no creatures.
Everything was just empty.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
What?
He's gone.
So the moon is evil.
The moon is evil.
We should save real quick.
Yeah, we should save.
Oh, good idea.
I'm spreading this information.
Alright, let's go back to the...
He's not a little creature, though.
Let's go back to that area.
Wait, is this one here or the other way?
I think it was the other way, right?
Yeah, okay.
Okay.
Hi!
He he.
I hear him.
I hear him breathing.
But I think it's a place we made open.
Moon's haunted.
And then...
We go...
Oh, do you hear that?
Easter egg.
Do we...
Do we drop down?
Oh.
Why not?
We can go up the stairs, if you go that way, to the...
Left, I think?
Is there anything else in here?
How do I get back?
I don't know.
Do you think we can get to the other side?
I don't remember.
I don't know.
I'm still lost.
Oh!
They're too fast, and why the hell are they walking on the ceiling?
Oh, no.
One of them spotted...
Oh!
It's the Covids!
Oh, it's the laboratory.
Oh, Doobie went the right way.
Hey, how do we get back?
How do we get back?
I don't...
I lost Doobie.
Oh, there...
Nevermind.
Must be a moon here.
Where exactly?
Oh, this is from the moon?
Maybe you guys should die.
Why?
Actually, we don't know where a save point is, though.
Don't die.
What is that sound?
Why is it so liquidy?
Hello?
Hi.
There's a whole...
There's like a maze area over here, but...
Wait, wait.
There's a save point right here.
Yeah.
Can you guys die?
Hello?
Oh, I'll go tell him.
I'll go tell him to die.
Okay.
Uh-oh.
Die!
Oh, shit.
I'm dead.
He came after me.
I have COVID.
Oh wait, everybody's dead.
He's dead.
Oh my gosh.
Watch out for COVID.
He's here.
Okay, one of us leads him away.
You can't hear, right?
Wait, wait, there's dark, there's dark.
Doobie, doobie, doobie.
Oh my gosh, he scared me.
I wish I could smash those orange heads.
Oh, that's another shortcut?
I'm so dead.
Wait, wait a second.
Wait, are we gonna lose that?
Are we gonna die?
Okay, we have to unlock that area again.
Yeah, but do you have the gun?
No, maybe we should leave it closed, right?
Right!
Oh yeah, yeah, we should leave it closed.
Yeah, you're right.
So true.
I have, I haven't...
Oh yeah, and then... Oh, okay, good, good, good.
Oh, this way?
I think there's, there's like the orange guy.
We gotta sneak past him.
Oh yeah, cause he can't get down.
So he can sneak it.
Oh, I hear that guy breathing on the other side.
Ooh.
He's right there.
Does that mean it could see us?
Yeah, it will see you.
And he's fast.
He will get you.
Oh shoot.
Wait, what's this?
Oh.
The password is somewhere nearby!
Oh my God!
The password is somewhere nearby.
Oh, nice!
Good job, Doobie!
I heard Min's final words were like, Password is somewhere near.
Password?
Who killed me?
Who's, who's sloppy body?
Who's...
Okay.
Our hero, Doobie.
We can't look at them too long or the...
Our fans get angry.
Alright, Doobie, what's the plan?
Doobie, you're muted!
Oh my God!
Everybody there?
No.
I hear him breathing.
I saw him over there.
I'm trapped a little bit.
I'm trapped.
I'm kind of trapped in here though.
Wait, I don't think that was the way to go anyway.
It was back here, right?
Or is it?
Oh wait, no, it was here.
Yeah.
I think we are supposed to pass.
What am I saying?
How about one of us bait them out and then the others run around?
You can, yeah, you can like kind of run past them.
You just gotta be careful.
Oh.
You can be the user's laptop.
You don't know the parents.
Is that the password is around here somewhere?
Oh my God.
Oh shoot.
Can they not come in here?
Hey, guys, hey?
Hey!
I don't think they can come in here.
Wait.
Is every... Wait.
Shoot.
No.
Okay.
I keep saying that, huh?
I can't come in here.
Uh-oh.
Come close.
What?
Okay, guys, take a picture.
Actually, take a picture.
Wait, what does it say?
Let me see it.
Five, one, one, two, one, five, one.
Holy hell, okay.
Five, one, one.
Okay, we're...
Okay, so like, where's the safe box?
I know where it is.
Well, kind of... Oh, okay.
I have seen it with my eyes.
Okay, it's fine.
Nimi was a hero.
She's... Watch out, watch out, watch out.
She's dead?
She was a hero.
Nimi, I'm trying to bring you home.
Okay.
All right, let's just... Let's just try for it.
I think I hear it.
Is this it?
I'm gonna die.
You're gonna die?
Okay.
Oh, oh.
Okay, we'll bring you back.
Oh, shoot.
The little slime creature.
All right, we'll bring you back.
We found the password.
Nice.
Yeah.
Yay.
You know where the safe... The safe box is, though.
I... Oh.
I... I... I ran past it once.
Is it way too long?
It is a very long password.
No, it is very, very long.
Watch out, there's a little slime guy in here, too.
As long as we don't look at him.
What?
You guys know where the safe box is?
Min says she knows where it is.
Well... Uh... I'm stuck on... One at a... One at a time, guys.
There can only be one.
Did we... Did we lose her?
Yeah, yeah.
We'll go back.
No, I don't think so.
Oh.
Yes, she did.
Oh, yeah.
There's... You two, like, stuff each other.
I didn't see anyone next to me, so...
I ran.
Oh.
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
Go back.
Hello, everybody!
Oh my god, the slime!
Run from the slime!
Oh my god.
Okay, is this the second floor?
This is the second floor.
Is the safe in our room?
Have we seen the safe before?
I don't remember.
There was one next to the map, but it didn't have this many digits.
There was something green that I was by, and that's where it said the password is close to here, and it was in that room.
Oh!
Oh, okay!
Yeah, yeah.
Think!
It was upstairs in that room, though.
Okay.
Okay, we can do this.
We just gotta have to invade the guy again.
Go!
Oh my god!
Oh wait, this is the first floor.
Yeah.
Uh, where was the save point here?
I don't remember.
Oh my god.
You little bastard.
They're dead, they're dead.
Okay.
Wasn't it by the elevator?
Oh my gosh.
Uh, over here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There was one.
The very first one we found.
Oh yeah, here we are.
Oh, we're back!
Okay.
Yeah, he double killed us.
Yeah.
Holy moly.
I left my password back there.
It's okay, chat remembers, right?
Chat!
I don't know if we have to.
Okay, I got it.
Alright.
Sink, guys.
Sink.
Where is the sink?
Well, this is the first floor, so we have to go to the second floor.
Yeah, we have to go back up.
Oh, you're right.
Okay.
I believe in doobies.
Guys, not up here.
I know.
Okay, so where have you seen the save?
It was in this library room somewhere.
This is where I got the plate.
I got this here.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
So...
Uh-oh, watch out, watch out for him.
One of us.
We have to go that way, huh?
One of us will remember.
I think we have to go that way.
Yeah, there's going over there.
There's here.
Oh, dear.
There's too much.
There's here.
Don't come over here.
Um, is he gonna come in here?
I don't know.
He's through the wall.
Oh, oh, he's here.
Oh, no.
He doesn't know.
He's not gonna come over here.
Did on the map?
What does that mean?
Oh, he's here.
Run, Divi!
Divi, run!
Oh.
Not like that.
Oh, Divi's trying to bring us back.
Hello?
Hi.
I'm gonna keep eating my syrup.
Oh, I don't know.
I don't know who's alive and who's not.
I'm so confused.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, my God.
One of us is alive.
One of us is still alive.
Hello?
Where are you?
I'm at the other save point.
I'll die or I'll go up there.
How are you guys doing?
I'm on the...
I'm drinking water.
I'm like with all the TV people.
Okay, I'm gonna die.
Okay, did you find the save?
I'm good.
Yeah, I'm gonna have fun.
I hope you guys have fun.
Did she find it?
I hear Nimi barely.
Should you find the save?
Hey.
Oh.
Oi.
I don't think he can see.
I don't think he knows.
Why is it...
Wait.
It shouldn't be the...
What?
How is she the main character?
How is she doing this?
Hello?
Hi.
Oh, oh, they're dead.
Yay!
Doobie, how did you do that?
I don't know.
What did he do?
I have my face between his cheeks.
Nice.
Hitting alien man's ass.
I didn't find any safe.
What about you?
You guys?
Oh, I didn't find any safe.
No, we were dead for a while.
We've been dead for a while.
We were just hiding.
Yeah.
Okay, what if somebody stays here and then...
So that we can revive and then somebody goes explore like...
Oh!
We go.
The library.
Okay, how do you do the emotes again?
I don't remember.
Oh, it's E?
G.
Oh, it's G.
Green women with the same brain.
Yeah!
I will go...
I will go look for it.
But let me see the thing again.
The plate.
Alright, who would be the driver of the...
The driver in Phasmophobia?
I'll sit here because my shift key sometimes doesn't work.
One, five, one.
You gotta get a new keyboard.
One, one, two.
Have you heard of the wooden keyboards?
Yeah.
One, five, one.
I guess you will.
One, one, two.
One, five.
One, five, one.
One, six, one.
It's like my personal mint radio.
I could fall asleep to that.
Really?
A lullaby, yes.
Oh.
A little... He won't follow us here.
No, no.
Okay.
I very vaguely remember where it was.
It was on the other far side of that room.
Uh-oh.
Are they dying over there?
Oh, that's somebody dying, yes.
Okay, I'm gonna run for it!
Wait.
Oh, maybe we should.
We're gonna have to get past him somehow, though.
Yeah.
Wait, Doki's still alive.
Yeah, let Doki stay there and we'll go through here.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, I'm going.
I'm going!
Uh-oh.
No, please!
I want to live!
Oh, I'm trapped?
I'm trapped?
Oh, I'm trapped.
Orangeheads cannot hear.
Yeah, I know.
But I don't know what...
Oh, come on!
Oh, where am I?
Oh, I'm back here!
Hi.
Hey, guys.
Where's Nimi?
Did she die?
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
Welcome back.
Well, go again.
Yeah.
I somehow stopped it.
I don't know how.
Wait, you stopped the password?
Wait, you guys know what it is?
Not the password.
I...
The guy, he stopped chasing after me.
I don't know why.
Oh.
It was weird.
Like, I hid here.
And he stopped chasing me.
Oh.
Maybe it's like the...
The...
Distance.
Alright.
Maybe.
I got you guys.
Okay.
We gotta find the safe.
Actually, are we close to the safe?
I don't know.
Oh, wait.
This is a nice hiding spot, too.
Look at that.
Oh, yeah.
Data...
Oh.
How do we even see the map?
I feel...
There must definitely be a moon here.
Oh, this is where we're at.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Is it time?
I don't think so.
I've tried that before.
I remember.
Probably didn't go past this door.
Ah.
I haven't seen it.
But Min says she has.
So...
It was green!
I saw!
Do you guys know what I'm talking about?
It was right at the spot where it said...
Min says she saw it.
So it's like somewhere here.
Unless we're at the wrong house.
Guys, is it here?
Is the safe even here, guys?
Or are we going the wrong way this entire time?
Holy cow!
I swear to God.
We've been like going the wrong way the entire time.
I...
I don't know anymore.
Oh, it is here.
Okay.
At least we know it's here.
Closer to the left path.
Okay, okay.
We're all relying on Min's memory right now.
Where the safe is.
So...
I did see it though!
She is the only one out of all of us that has seen it.
So I hope...
I hope it's right.
It was definitely in that maze area.
Guys!
Oh, I found it!
What is it?
What's the number?
One...
Five...
I found it!
I said take a screenshot!
One...
There's no eight!
There's no eight.
Okay.
Five...
One...
Two...
Five...
One, one, two... My chat's good.
You guys are so good and helpful.
Teacher of the song.
Someone take the screenshot!
Oh, everybody else is dead.
One, one, two, one, five, one.
One, two... One, five, one, one, five, one, five, one, five, one, five, one.
Donkeybird, please, one, five, one.
Oh my God, streamer, listen to me.
Streamer, please!
Streamer, please, listen to my voice!
One, two, five.
What was that?
You hear that?
I hear Nimi too.
One, five, one, five, five, five, one, two, one, two, one.
Wait, is that the... It is the...
No, it's the... I don't know how to get out though.
She better live.
Oh my God.
Wait, that guy just phased out of existence.
Oh my God, I'm fucking trapped.
Donkeybird, live.
Live.
I'm quoting Naomi Hunter.
You must live.
Doobie?
Nope.
Doobie, Doobie, Doobie, Doobie.
What are you?
Please, revive us!
Doobie?
Oh my God, Doki, please.
Go, go save.
Please.
Oh my God, what are you doing?
What happened?
What did you do?
Good job!
I told you I saw it.
I told you.
Alright, nobody... You should have learned my song.
Five.
One, one, two.
One, five, one.
The chat was just boobs and boobies.
It only like, one or two people had the right code, but my chat kept spamming boob, so I couldn't get it.
So what does this go to?
Um, it's on the outside, remember the...
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
Just one more electrical board.
Yeah, we just need one.
But how do we get downstairs?
Uh...
Oh, and the other one must be in the other safe box.
By the map.
Oh!
Oh, watch out, this is where the worm is?
You guys, there's the...
Do we have to go this way?
Yeah, why are we going this way?
Yeah, I don't know.
Why did we choose the path of the most resistance?
I'm just exploring, I don't know.
Um...
I heard death right behind me!
Who?
Who died?
Nobody!
Oh!
Yes, they did.
Nobody!
Well, it wasn't saving!
Somebody!
Wait, I remember we unlocked the door that went downstairs.
Did we?
No, we didn't...
We didn't blow it up, did we?
No, we did, we did.
We unlocked the area, see?
Oh, okay.
Oh, just kidding.
You're right.
What?
You know the way.
I'm so lost in this game, damn.
It's here.
This is where the thing was.
The moon is barely right below us.
Yeah!
The moon!
Free the moon!
Oh!
It's one last task!
We have one last thing to do!
Do we want to try and get the secret way to the basement?
Nah, that's not that important, right?
Oh, sorry.
He's helping the guy.
Yeah.
Okay.
What has he ever done for us?
So true!
Yeah, I know.
We gave him a TV and then he left, right?
Yeah, yeah.
And he was like, see ya, suckers.
Maybe we're supposed to follow him.
Like, where did he go?
Did he just float off?
He said there's like a secret way to the basement outside, but whatever.
Yeah, we don't need to know that.
Nah.
So where do we find the password for the safe box?
Northwest of the grounds.
Does anyone know their cardinal directions?
Uh...
Never eat soggy waffles.
Oh, the map!
Oh wait, if we get the scanner...
Maybe the scanner has a...
Oh, that's true.
What's the blue thing on the map?
Wait, you can pull up the map?
Yeah, press tab.
Wait, I totally tried that last time too though.
Oh my god!
What?
What's the manager?
What's the map this entire time?
Squat!
Wait, what is the button?
Tab!
Tab?
Why didn't you tell us this?
I just...
I thought...
I tried it last time and it didn't work.
Oh...
Why is there a pin on the map?
Yeah, that's what I'm looking at.
The little blue pin.
That's the next...
Uh...
Safe box?
Yeah.
It's right here.
We can go check it out.
Alright.
Like, it's right here.
No?
Wait, I can't believe we had...
Maybe it's inside?
Yeah, what is this?
The secret way to the basement?
Oh my god!
It's the secret way to the basement!
Oh, this is...
We did it!
We figured it out!
Yeah!
Oh...
It was just marked on the map.
What?
I couldn't see.
I was scared.
Wait, I don't wanna be first.
I'm scared.
What if the...
Okay, but...
Is either first or behind...
Or the last?
Wait, where's the TV head?
Where are...
Every time Doobie said it looks safe...
The guy can go, so...
I found...
A door?
What is this?
It's dark up ahead.
Better bring a light.
Oh.
Okay, so...
We have to go forward for the TV head.
It's...
Yeah, I think it's in here.
There's a guy over there!
Oh, there it is?
Okay.
Yeah, he's right there.
But he can only get...
Oh, he walked away, see?
He walked away.
Oh wait, there's...
He's over here too.
Who is this way?
Did someone bring a light?
No.
We gotta go get one.
And then...
Maybe...
It was over here.
Wait, I hear breathing.
Me too.
I hear breathing.
What?
I see.
Yeah, the one's breathing.
Oh, it's the meow meows.
Oh wait, oh shoot.
Why is he in here?
Um...
Sorry, I brought him over here.
Oh my god, he's so loud.
The meow meows.
Uh...
You look so ominous over there.
Yeah, but he...
Those are easy to avoid.
Oh.
Is Doki dead?
No!
That last time I saw.
Is there just one?
Yeah.
Oh.
I saw like a half down, I think.
Hello!
Wait, we found another save terminal.
I think it's the same one.
No, I don't think so.
Wait.
Oh?
Oh.
Oh, way down here?
Oh, we should have brought a light.
Maybe we can't see it.
I just...
I guess they did say to bring the light.
What's that sound?
Hello?
Oh, he's straight there.
Oh!
Let's go.
Oh, I found this man.
I talked to him.
It says talk to...
Oh, follow TV head!
We gotta follow him.
Wait, where do you go?
I can't see anything.
Where do you go?
Oh, God.
Wait, we lost him.
Oh, no!
He's in here!
Here!
This way!
I'm following him real close.
I'm following him.
I know.
Look at him go.
Little alien.
Just a little guy.
What did he want to go to?
Where are we?
Maybe he'll find the password.
5...
1...
2...
5...
1...
I swear to God.
If the monster is like, literally right behind us while we're...
He's right behind me.
Oh wait, he led us to an elevator.
Oh.
Is Doobie alive?
I don't think so.
Hey, hey.
We're almost at the laboratory.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, that's the secret entrance to the laboratory.
Okay.
This is the most convoluted entrance to the laboratory.
Are we gonna perform surgery on this thing?
When does he turn orange?
Wait.
This is...
This room does not feel safe.
What was that?
Is he gonna kill us?
Is he the final boss?
I don't...
I don't trust him.
Look at him.
He's just...
smiling at us.
Is there COVID in here?
No?
There's a safe station!
Oh, nice, nice.
Oh, do we just follow him first?
I think so.
Yeah, just follow him for now.
Wait, there's a giant ass button.
What happened?
Just...
Talk to him.
Okay, let's stay...
Let's get to be here.
Hold on, hold on.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, sorry, sorry.
Oh, he wants the orange down there.
Wait, you're gonna turn into a COVID head!
Don't do it!
Okay, wait, wait, let's...
Let's get to be here first.
Guys.
Alright.
Hi!
Welcome back!
Alright, who's good at...
Thank you.
He's gonna turn into a COVID head!
What is this?
I pressed it.
You're playing a video game now.
Where is the grabber?
Oh, it's a game pad.
Yeah.
Oh, I see it!
Over there!
Over there, you gotta move it.
Oh, okay.
Who's good at...
Who's good at this?
Not me.
I didn't even know who's moving.
I flub it every time.
Keep going left.
Left.
You're...
You're good.
You're good, you're good, you're good.
Tell me, you want to stop.
You're good.
Stop!
Oh!
Just a little bit over to the left more.
Oh.
Go back, go back.
Back, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
Stop.
I didn't stop.
Oh, I have to press it again.
Okay.
I'm gonna stop.
Stop.
To the left a little.
A little bit more, I think.
Try now.
Drop?
Alright.
Oh, so close.
Come on.
A little more to the left.
And then... A little back?
Yeah, a little... Oh wait.
Yeah, a little back.
What?
Okay.
And a little more to the left.
Right?
Left?
Guys!
Oh my god.
Is it even open?
A little tiny bit right.
Okay guys, first off, is it open?
I don't know.
Yeah!
Left!
Okay.
And... More left!
More left!
More back!
More left, more back!
Okay.
Is this good?
Yeah.
Yeah, send it!
A little more back!
How precise is this?
There.
Drop it.
Drop it like it's high.
What?
Okay.
Are you serious?
I don't think this is... this is gonna happen.
Guys, I swear to god, if this was not open in...
Wait, what?
How do we do that?
It's rigged.
Like your red crane game.
Oh wait, left?
Left?
Stop?
Where's our perspective?
Is there a...
Stop, just press it.
You press it again to stop it.
Yeah.
Did I get it?
Oh!
It was our perspective!
Thank you!
I just got lucky.
I couldn't see it.
Ah!
Oh, and then we did pull it back to him.
Us.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, put it on and put it on.
Wait, he's gonna die!
Wait, I'm gonna use...
I'm gonna use the vacuum.
Someone else do it.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
Wait, you're gonna die, Doki.
You're right here.
Wait, it's gonna touch you!
Doki, why did you stop right there?
Just let her die.
Yeah, well...
Yeah.
Wait, is it...
Okay.
That's as far as it goes.
Yeah, it's as far as it goes.
Maybe talk to him and then he's like, oh...
Wait, I can grab it.
Oh!
Okay.
I don't think this is gonna be good.
Talk to him.
This is a good orange.
Just what we need.
We'll be able to install it in the operating room.
We are performing surgery!
Doki will follow us.
Hello.
We'll come pick her up.
I'll come back.
Yeah, we'll pick her up.
We'll pick her up.
There's an operating room?
It's a lab, so it can't be fun.
Is this part of the...
What we have to do?
I wonder.
Because would they really program a side quest into this game?
That's true.
It also was on the map.
Like the secret, you know?
What's this?
Yeah.
Oh.
I'll wait for...
I'll wait for Doki.
But there's something here, too.
Good lord.
After the head replacement procedure, it is imperative to immediately initiate a full memory wipe of the subject.
Oh.
Even brief retention of previous neural links can lead to undesirable side effects.
Patients who have undergone the operation exhibit a radical shift in spatial orientation.
Their perception of gravity becomes inverted, which may trigger escape attempts.
Errors at this stage are unacceptable.
Oh.
That's why they're on the ceiling.
That's why they walk on the ceiling.
Yeah.
And this guy wants to be an orange because?
Why?
Maybe because all his friends are orange.
I guess so.
Yeah.
He feels a little...
He's got no color in his world.
I believe.
Oh, hey.
Hi.
You guys are just carrying the head just like that.
It's time to replace the head.
I'm about to perform surgery.
We're gonna do a surgery on the alien.
Yeah.
It's like the...
It's like the Mei Mei say.
Okay.
Here I go.
Eh?
First, you need to remove the TV.
Then, you put the orange in its place.
Why does he want this?
I'm ready to be a TV head with no TV.
Let's hope it all goes right.
Oh.
It's gonna be built different.
It's not gonna be like the other one.
It's pretty.
Oh my god, he's T-posing.
He's...
He's T-posing.
I'm taking...
Wait, I can't...
Can someone else take the head?
Or...
Yeah, take it.
Yeah, there you go.
Oh.
I took it.
I'm applying the item.
What?
Oh my god, that's how you think...
Wait, I think he'll be...
Isn't he evil now?
Yes.
Maybe?
No, he seems cool.
Yeah, he's cool now.
Another orange head.
Oh, he's...
He won't talk to me.
Oh?
Dot, dot, dot, dot.
Dot, dot, dot.
Dot, dot?
Maybe we need to bring him something.
Oh, he's talking to me.
What the hell?
What?
Oh, he didn't like you.
He didn't like you.
I think I've got an orange for a head now.
Yay.
For some reason I feel drawn upward.
That's unusual.
Yeah, that's weird.
Maybe somebody else has to talk to him now.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Your turn, Mimi.
Okay.
I think I might be able to try something.
I'll be in the courtyard of the main building.
Oh!
Where's the courtyard?
Wait, guys, remember this...
The other dead...
Dead alien?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Maybe he'll tell us the codes.
Oh.
I don't think we can open that.
Heck no.
We gotta find the...
So, we gotta go to the courtyard.
And then...
Also, we gotta give the...
The other dead alien this other TV.
Yeah.
I feel like that was so far away.
Okay, yeah.
How did we get down?
The guide led us here.
How do we get back?
I don't know.
We don't have a flashlight.
We could save real quick, too.
Maybe?
Okay, we save.
We save.
Yeah.
We never went this way.
Maybe this way...
Wait, we have a map.
We have a map.
No map.
We have a flashlight.
Oh, wait.
We have a...
The flashlight.
Oh my gosh.
There's a basement.
Oh, isn't this where we die if we walk?
Yeah, yeah.
And then from there, we can take the elevator to go to the first floor.
How do we...
Wait, is there nothing here?
Oh...
This way.
Can we take this?
Oh.
No?
Why is it so...
There's nothing here.
Yeah.
Oh, there's...
Oh.
How mysterious.
Oh, it is...
Oh.
We're here.
Oh, this is so handy.
Oh, there's a...
Yeah.
There's a little goo guy, so let's...
Let's go.
Yeah.
We don't look at them.
He can't get in the elevator, right?
No.
No one can get in the elevator.
None of the aliens can get in.
No.
They're not loud.
Was it the...
It was the...
Third floor?
Third floor.
Yeah, we're in the first floor right now.
Okay.
We're doing it, guys.
We just need...
I wanna watch Cartoon Network.
No, I'm a...
I'm a Nickelodeon kid.
Dexter's lab is on.
Come on.
Yeah.
We're here.
Wait, what are we doing here?
Oh, the other elevator.
Yeah.
Alright.
We're almost there.
What are we doing?
Uh...
Wait, what do we do first?
The TV or the courtyard?
Um...
What's closer?
Whichever.
I think...
I think the TV's closer, right?
Well, I mean, we have to go to the courtyard first, to be fair, but...
Yeah.
Maybe a TV?
Just in case.
The TV would be a little more dangerous.
Is it the first floor or the basement?
Basement?
I don't...
It'll come back to us when we see.
Wait, we have a map.
Why are we asking each other this?
There's no map data.
Check it.
Oh...
I think it's only for outside.
Oh, and someone said first floor.
Let's go do that.
There's just one guy.
Um, excuse...
It's two guys.
Um...
One is a member, and one isn't.
Oh...
Okay.
Oh, it's here!
Oh!
Oh?
Where are we?
And then we go to the second floor.
Wait, no, see?
Oh, he's here.
Oh, here's the courtyard.
There he is!
Yeah, there he is!
He's...
He's waiting for us.
He's upside down.
Is he just gonna float away if he walks out of the stairwell?
I know!
What happens to him?
Yeah.
Wait, he's...
He's sitting up there.
He's so cute!
Aww.
Hi!
Hey!
I think I'll be better there.
Feels like I could jump.
Really?
What's stopping me?
Just the thought of how long I'll keep falling.
That scares me a bit.
Aww.
I'll keep going again.
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Thank you.
I couldn't have done any of this without you.
It's time for me to go.
No!
Oh, no!
Wait!
Did we do the right thing?
07 in the chat.
Wait, it says visit the operating room in the laboratory again.
Okay, do we do the...
I guess we should go to the operating room, right?
Okay.
That's where we just were.
Yeah.
I think so.
I think we should do the TV guy first though.
I see...
Okay.
I think this progresses the story.
And I think the other one was like a bonus side quest.
Yeah, I think so too.
That's fair.
Yeah, so we should do the side quest for just to see.
Cause I think it's a reward for competing it.
I got it.
Okay.
Yeah, me too.
Me too.
It was like that song.
What was that?
Do do do do do do do do do do.
Do do do do do.
Oh, yeah.
Wait.
How do we get to the elevator because it's...
Here, here.
Okay.
Yeah, and then...
Laboratory.
Yeah, we're doing it, guys.
Got it.
His final message was for us to go to the operating room.
Yeah, but why?
Maybe there's like a tracker on him.
Yeah, maybe.
Do you think he... Do you think he's still floating in space right now?
Yeah.
I thought he was gonna go to the moon.
He's probably not there yet.
He's going to the moon.
Another moon.
Wait, why are we following Min?
Because the elevator's right here.
That's stupid.
I don't remember what floor was that.
Oh, it wasn't the first floor?
Yeah.
The first floor?
Oh my god, am I holding the TV while doing this?
Yeah, you are.
Whoa.
And then over here to the... Pretty gnarly, guys.
Gnarly.
Everything's gnarly.
Yeah.
Oh, this way?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I remember.
And then there's the operating table.
Yeah, yeah.
All the way down here.
But what do we have to do here again, I wonder?
I don't know.
I think he just gave us something.
Yeah, yeah.
See?
What is it?
Final message.
Oh!
Change the world.
What's it say?
Place the... Oh!
Place the crystal inside to upgrade it.
The upgrade crystal is capable of destroying the oranges.
Oh!
That would be huge!
That would be huge.
Look on the other side.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All the way over here.
It's like, only one of you guys have to do that.
Yeah!
Crystal!
Could be huge.
Wait.
This?
I think so.
Yeah.
It said crystal.
Yeah, yeah.
That's it, I think.
Okay.
Woohoo!
Kinda messed up killing all his friends though, isn't it?
Oh!
What if he dies up there?
Yeah!
Oh, yeah!
It's okay, he's in space.
Wait, so where do I put it?
In the box, right?
Place the crystal inside to upgrade it.
Yeah, yeah.
This box.
Oh.
Wait.
Did I upgrade?
I don't think that's the right...
Oh!
Whoa!
It does, me too!
It's upgraded.
Yay!
Also, we got, like, a special little thing to... because of...
I take it!
Yeah!
All right.
Let's go find a TD.
Are they dead then?
Let's see.
They were down here.
Oh.
I can't.
But we have to take... we have to, like, go up towards them, right?
Yeah, I guess so.
Yeah, yeah.
It's, like, AOE.
Oh!
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, just save.
Oh, save, save, save.
I'm coming, I'm coming!
Yay!
Okay.
So now we can go do the last password easily.
Yeah, we'll be able to walk through that, like, whole area.
Yeah.
Where is the password, though?
I don't know.
We'll figure it out.
No, we have a map now.
We have a map.
Oh, yeah.
True.
True!
Alright.
We got this.
The Super Cheeto.
Everything's coming together.
I believe.
Alright.
Got my TV.
We got our Cheeto.
We're ready to get him.
We're gaming?
Yeah.
I'm ready for our lap party, guys.
Let's go!
That's a good question.
Is the crystal upgrade permanent?
Or do we have to do it every time?
Well, we're not gonna lose it, so we don't have to worry about it.
Yeah.
Was it first floor?
Exactly.
Oh, yeah, it's first floor.
Whoa!
Okay.
The TV head guy is on the second floor.
So we got...
Whoa!
Go, guys.
Woo!
Okay.
Does anyone know how to get to the second floor?
Um, we got...
Maybe we could go from the court...
We're from the annex, right?
Uh...
Oh, here, here, here!
Yeah.
Found it.
Oh!
Easy peasy.
Uh, TV head.
Oh, we're gonna go kill them?
No, no, no.
The...
We're gonna give him the last alien the TV.
Yeah, let's give the last...
The other alien the TV first, I think.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't remember where he was.
I remember the first guy was here, but...
Yeah, he's all the way up down here.
He was a close spy.
He's right here.
Oh, okay.
Hello, TV man.
Take the TV.
Hello.
Do you want an orb, too?
You want...
Oh, he's happier.
Yeah.
Oh.
Hello?
Uh, hello?
You kind of remind me of something.
Did you even know...
Creatures like you...
Pissed off the little black liquid creatures?
They got all bothered and now...
Well, this is happening.
Yeah, what, me?
Yeah, you.
And, uh...
You sort of plugged the TV into me.
Now I can't even look away from all this weirdness.
Oh my...
He's not grateful at all.
He didn't help...
Why did he go?
Oh!
Look what you did!
You didn't ask for his consent.
To have a TV on his head.
You are the one holding the TV!
No.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Wait, we should go save over here real quick.
Like...
Oh yeah, let's see this.
He's so...
Oh, there's a guy!
There's a guy!
I hear him.
Wait, what kind of guy?
It's the...
It's the Slenderman.
Yeah.
The one that...
Boys gets us.
Okay, now...
Look at the map.
Yeah, maybe the map will tell us.
Maybe we go to courtyard?
Will tell us?
Okay.
What do you mean the courtyard?
Why would the courtyard tell us?
Because we have to get out of the building.
Of the ground.
It says the ground, so I assume it's outside.
Oh, northwest of the ground.
Oh, there's the...
The other guy is over there.
Wait, how do we...
I know that the...
There's the safety box is where the map was.
But I don't know where the password is.
Northwest.
Yeah, because we need to find the password for it.
It says northwest of the ground, so...
Maybe the...
Okay, guys.
You know our cardinal directions now, right?
Yeah.
Okay, so there's a staircase here.
East.
Alright, let's go downstairs.
There's like...
Yeah...
And then...
Is there a...
Slendermarm?
I'm at Matt now.
Where's Northwest?
Oh, I'm on somebody's set.
Oh, that's where that building is, where that, uh...
Face guy?
Yeah, yeah, where the face guy is bothering us.
Oh...
And we know what to do.
Oh, where do we find the password?
Oh, he's like right there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He goes through the gate, so be careful.
Oh, he does?
We'll wait for him to go back the other way.
Okay, there he goes.
There he goes.
Look at him go.
We're looking for a password, okay.
Yeah, it says Northwest of the ground.
Around here, does it mean?
What's that thing?
I think so.
Did you just say, what is Northwest?
I mean, where is Northwest?
Uh-oh.
He's coming, he's coming.
Oh my god, guys, we gotta split up.
I think he's on me.
If I die, feed my cats.
Stupid.
Hold on, I'm taking a sippy of water real quick.
Oh shit.
Oh, no sippy of water.
No sippy of water.
Oh my god.
I gotta go in there.
I know where they are.
Okay, I'm gonna try.
Actually, where is he?
Oh, I see him.
Oh shit.
I don't wanna die.
Password?
No.
I didn't get the password.
Wait, you got a special what?
Oh, frickin' lame reading.
Aww.
Merge.
I'm gonna check again.
Oh, I use here.
Oh, this one.
Oh.
It's a five.
I know, right?
One.
One, two.
Two?
One later.
Okay.
Wait.
One of the numbers is three.
How do you...
Okay.
Come over here, guys.
I'll show you what I know.
What do you know?
Oh.
I'm still alive.
One of them was three.
I don't know what...
How did you...
I didn't see how you saw what the number was, though.
If you go up to that tree, and then you look down, and there's a number three on it.
What?
Do you think it's the five trees?
No.
Oh, it's this.
Oh, there are five.
These are the three numbers.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
So, the three...
The three is...
Okay.
Wait.
It says one...
Okay.
Number two is three.
Oh, my God.
This is hellish.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna go look for number one.
I see.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Does he turn around?
Yes, he does.
Okay.
He's turned around.
Alright.
What's yours?
What trees?
Just follow your heart, Nimi.
Just follow your heart.
Wait, is there...
Which way is...
Wait, I see.
We all have to stick together to go to our area anyway.
And then we'll have to get up.
Is it like over here?
No, no, no.
It's on the other side.
It's on the other side of the gate.
It is?
Number one?
Is it over here?
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
My big butt can't get through the door.
I hate the way these things breathe, man.
They're so scary.
I'm kinda confused, though.
Like, what is all this foliage, you know?
Like, it looks like it should be in there, no?
Just use my map.
Oh, look at that!
I can see them alive!
That's crazy!
Please don't kill me.
I don't think it's outside.
I really can't tell.
I'm trying my best.
Maybe it is.
One!
I'm stupid!
We're in the trees!
Okay!
You guys saw the number, right?
You guys saw my number, right?
What?
You're crazy, right?
No, I didn't see it.
Okay!
Alright, come and follow me!
We're all gonna see you.
Okay.
Maybe one person can only see one number on each tree.
Do you see this number?
Oh!
I thought you meant the glowing tree.
Three!
There's a three!
Okay, let's check all the normal trees in this area then.
Is that two or...
That's number two, yeah, that's two.
That's number two?
Yeah.
Okay.
So, straight...
Whatever direction.
This way...
I was trying to find number one, but I couldn't find it.
Why?
It has to be the other side!
You think so?
Yeah, right?
No, I think it can't be because it would be too easy.
Where would it be then?
I don't know.
I was looking over here.
I don't see any other number.
It's been here.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Nine!
Or six!
Six or nine, right here.
Oh, oh!
Um, I think it's six.
I think it's six.
I can't tell.
Wait, you might be right.
I think I got ambushed by somebody's body.
Was it on the map?
It was me.
I'm sorry.
It's okay.
I thought the map was the cars.
I ambushed you.
Car battery stuff.
You were hiding in the bush.
You were like...
It was true.
Guerilla warfare.
I think they stood up.
Yippee!
I got another number.
Oh, which one?
It's either six or nine.
The one over here.
Okay.
There should be another three.
Oh, nice!
Revive us, please!
Revive us!
Okay.
Thank you!
Let's see.
Which one was yours, though?
Was it the one or the three?
Oh, it's either six or nine.
We don't know.
Mine was one.
Mine was...
It's six?
Okay.
One.
Okay, so...
Then three is like up ahead.
And...
Okay.
I pulled up my map.
Three is close to one.
And five is also...
They're in that kind of square little area.
Yeah.
If someone can lead the guy away, then...
I'll do it!
You will?
I believe in him!
The hero!
Wait, where is he?
Oh, he's over where we need to go.
Just kidding.
Okay.
All right.
There should be one...
So, this is the one that I just found.
This is the one you found.
Yeah.
There should be one maybe around over here.
Or...
Mr. Eyeball.
There's five!
You found five?
Yeah, it's right here.
Oh, I see it!
So, that's...
Okay.
Five.
I'll go put it in.
Okay.
That way.
Because...
I'll remember.
Five.
Okay.
So, that was...
Number...
Three is five.
Okay.
So, you need...
I can't read that.
Four...
Okay.
Oh!
Oh, everybody's alive.
Look at that.
That's crazy.
Oh!
Hello!
Hi!
That guy just almost got your butt.
Wait.
Did people die?
I don't think so.
No, they're...
Oops.
They're on their way.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
I'll keep distracting him.
Oh, you guys got it.
A six or a nine.
At the far end.
That would be the fourth digit.
Okay.
The fourth one?
Uh...
Yeah, so...
I'll just...
Oh!
We did it!
Yay!
We did it again!
Get here!
We can beat the game!
Yay!
Wait.
Should we save again?
Yeah, let's save again.
Save again.
Good idea.
Nice.
Okay.
Let's go.
Let's go save the moon.
Get rid of the moon.
Get rid of the creatures!
Yeah!
We'll have two moons on Earth, guys.
Woohoo!
Cool moons!
Just keep running.
Just don't ignore the footsteps behind you.
We're good, we're good.
Yeah, we're fine.
Wait, is this the one that we have to do inside at the laboratory?
No, no, no.
This one's outside.
Oh, okay, okay.
Am I holding it still?
Yeah, yeah, you got it.
Oh, it's this one, that's right.
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited!
Ready?
We did it!
Wait, wait, I don't know actually if this ends the game, but...
I hope so!
Not that I'm not enjoying my time spent with you all.
Yeah, I was like, we just wanna see the moon!
Yeah, I'm going in.
The moon?
It won't let me.
Open the hatches?
Is it gonna come out?
Wait, it's coming, it's coming out!
The moon is rising!
Oh!
Oh, it's getting quicker!
Oh, sorry guys.
Get on!
Yeah!
Oh my god, you're right!
So are you guys seeing Jake's up or Edward, guys?
Right?
Obviously.
Whoa!
Oh, look!
It's sucking the creatures in!
Oh!
Wait!
My girlfriend wants to talk to me.
Sorry, hold on.
Wait, why does the moon even glow?
Because the moon is only lit up by the sun.
Wait, guys, it's not over.
Is this a moonrise?
Oh, that's what she just said.
Wait.
Oh, we got everything done, didn't we?
It's blocked by the energy dome.
It's awesome.
There's an energy dome.
Oh my god!
Oh shit!
We were so close!
Wait, when it says two out of two, and one out of one.
Yeah.
Oh, I think it's everywhere we've been to.
And then we just like...
Oh, we...
Okay.
Wait, what's an energy return?
You just press a button.
Oh!
Look at the map!
Oh, the valves!
Oh, that's a vampire.
So there's one...
Inside here?
Yeah.
But you gotta be careful.
There is.
Oh, so that's not too hard.
Oh, get me!
Get me!
Okay, one of us has to...
There's a guy!
Our wife will save us!
Yeah, girlfriend saved me!
Did he save us?
She'll find him.
Yeah, she will.
Oh.
Did someone die?
I think so.
I think I heard somebody scream.
Wait, shall we go to the s...
Where's the safe point?
Was this one gotten then?
I guess so.
Oh wait, I can do the same point over here.
The first one, I think.
Okay, cool, cool.
Yeah.
Nice.
It was near me.
Right here.
Oh, we're back.
Welcome back.
Okay, I got... I...
Wait, there's one like right here.
Hello?
She's actually Blair Witching.
Wait, oh no.
I said Toki just sent my game correct.
Wait, let me turn them up.
Hello?
I hope they didn't get kicked out.
We got kicked out.
Yeah, you were Blair Witching in the corner.
Alright.
This will be fast.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, it should be fun.
Thank you.
You guys can change your colors now.
Guys, at least we can be your colors now.
Hello?
Yeah.
One second, guys.
Hello?
Oh!
I didn't get to change my colors!
Wait, what happened to the numbers?
They changed.
Did they change?
Yeah, they did.
No, no.
It's the same.
For me.
It's...
1...
1-2.
Oh, okay.
Mine was messed up then.
I was excited about me and my colors!
I...
Yeah...
That's why I pressed art.
Ew!
Wait, where's that?
There's one in a...
There's one, like, right here.
But how do we get to it?
I think it's in one of these...
Wait.
Yeah, right there it's rolling.
How do we get there?
Yeah.
Just go over here, I think.
You can just go in, right?
Oh!
You're so smart.
Oh, my God.
Thanks.
Don't worry, guys.
I'll get this one.
You guys can get the rest.
Oh, the second floor and basement!
Second floor and basement?
I wish to now say two out of two.
Oh!
Okay, okay, so...
Wasn't it supposed to be like this the whole time?
Yeah.
Guys, we gotta go...
Go to the second floor or the basement.
Okay.
No, it's this way.
I believe in that...
Wait.
Why can't I see anything on my map, though?
That's not serious.
There we go.
Wasn't this the basement over here?
No.
Yeah, where's this...
Where's the...
The door from the basement?
I don't know.
Isn't it right here?
There's stairs over here.
Oh, you're here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's right here.
Okay.
We found one over here.
Yeah.
Watch out, that guy.
Oh, hi.
Same way.
Guys, we never found the map data for the basement.
Oh, no.
Wait, but it's like right by the...
I remember seeing it right by the door.
You do?
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Basement or basement two?
I did basement two because you said second floor basement.
Oh, oh, it is.
Second floor.
See?
Open the map.
This way, this way, this way.
Okay.
Be careful.
Another side.
Oh, we have to go past...
Him.
Oh, he's right there.
He's right there.
Wait, no.
We go forward.
What?
I said be careful.
Why did you go forward?
Well, Doki can get it.
Oh.
He's chasing her.
I see her running on the map.
Oh, she's got it.
She got it.
All right.
Now she can die.
We'll go rest.
Yeah.
Um, we're...
Just die, Doki.
We'll bring you back.
Wait, where's the elevator again?
Right here.
Where it is.
Basement.
I wonder if she's dead.
Thank you for being a hero, D.V.
We're both heroes.
Yeah, we're all heroes.
Yeah.
We've all been great.
Guys, heroes never die, guys.
True.
So now...
Okay, second floor.
Second floor.
Oh, it's like right here.
Oh, easy.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I've left it.
Is that it?
I thought the game was...
And then we go to the moon.
Got it?
Yeah, yeah.
Almost the end!
We did it.
We're gonna miss me.
We're gonna miss.
Go go go go go go.
Go go go!
There you go.
It's beautiful.
Oh my God, it will rise to a level where you can approach it and take flight.
Wait, do we have to go to the ceiling?
What?
The roof?
That's what the manager just said.
Why do we get to the roof?
Begin the flight.
Wait...
Are we going to the moon?
The moon will push... Take the elevator to the roof!
This way, this way, this way!
Remember, it's the meow, remember the meow-meows.
Meow-meows!
And meow-meows.
Meow-meows.
There's a marker on the map.
Yeah.
Oh, there is?
Oh.
Okay, maybe not the meow-meows.
Yeah, you're going the wrong way.
Oh my god.
Okay, does someone else need?
Yeah, someone with the map.
Mimi, we nominate you.
It's this way.
Oh no.
Right?
Maybe I'm going the wrong way.
Yeah.
In here.
This way.
That way?
Hello, little creature.
This way.
Please ignore me.
And it's, like, right in front of us.
Oh, right here.
Oh!
Oh, is this always here?
Yeah.
Um, yeah.
I don't know.
Did you just never see this elevator?
Wait, did I?
Oh, it's coming.
Yeah, yeah.
It's just a little slow.
Yeah, it's coming.
Don't let that guy in.
He's creepy.
He's going.
Don't.
Yeah, go.
Oh.
Back to the roof.
That could be Wraith right now.
You don't know that.
Wraith?
Yeah, he's been with us the whole time in Spear.
Yeah, he's been with us.
That's a little scary, though.
Yeah.
Whoa.
It's a cat.
Oh, the cat.
Can we talk to her?
Fly away with the moon is our objective.
Kitten.
The girlfriend's over here.
Yeah, I see her standing over there.
Oh.
She's coming home with me.
She's going to pick us up and spin us and throw us into the moon.
I hope so, actually.
Hello, giant woman.
Oh, okay.
Your wife's time.
She says, it seems like this is the end.
The moon is already waiting for you.
And yet you managed to pull it off.
That's it.
We're going home.
Fly away now.
Oh, you guys?
Wait, she's still talking?
My girl.
Goodbye, clever.
Yeah, you're missing your girlfriend's speech.
Oh, my bad.
She doesn't want to come to space with us.
You're not going to come to space with us.
Go on, sweetie.
There's a bridge here.
What's your final words to your wife?
I love you and latex.
It's time to say goodbye to this place and move on.
I'm not ready.
Okay, that's the last thing she says.
All right.
It's time, guys.
Are we all ready?
Yeah.
Let's go.
I'll never forget you, space lady.
Thank you for making her the happiest mess around.
I'll never forget the bachelor party.
Wait, are we actually going to see space now?
That'd be crazy.
I mean, that's why we put on the space.
Then the real game starts.
Yeah, the real.
Are you guys ready?
Oh, she's a little small.
Set out on a journey.
I know, right?
We're going to live inside of it.
We'll all have to be nearby.
Here we go.
Oh, oh.
Moonwalking?
It's us.
I can't believe I'm white now.
Everybody else got to put on their color.
Oh, there we go.
Girlfriend.
I lost my girlfriend.
I lost my cat.
Worst ending ever.
Bye.
Oh, I wish we could all talk to each other.
Are all the creatures going to disappear?
Oh, the mission is complete.
Says manager-san.
Once you reach the border, our agents will pick you up outside.
Over and out.
Finish the...
Look at us.
We're tiny.
We're tiny little dots.
Yay!
Oh, let me...
I was gonna unmute them, but it...
It like...
Cuts the game audio.
I can still hear that thing breathing, though.
Hello?
We're back?
How do we...
Why are we back?
New gameplays!
I thought we all flew away.
Wait.
What happened?
Where is...
Wait, the creatures are still here, even.
Oh, my God.
Wait, like...
Did we not...
We beat the game, though.
Yeah, we beat it.
We beat it.
I got a scheme achievement.
Yeah.
Like, it was...
We got kicked off the moon.
A cat!
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Oh, scary.
Aw, he's happy.
He's fine.
He's secure.
He's not evil anymore.
Wait, is the moon up there?
Wait.
Maybe...
Maybe this was for, like, the TV head guy.
If you put the orange on his head when the moon is already out.
Then he, like, lives on the moon with us.
But since we did it early, he just floated off into endlessly.
Oh, he's just...
We did the order of operations a little wrong.
Wait, I thought the creatures were supposed to be gone, though.
I still see them walking around.
Oh, wait.
There's two TV heads here we could talk to.
Maybe they're gonna fly away.
Oh, yeah.
Strange.
You left with the moon, then?
Yeah, we thought so.
Yeah, we all floated away.
Yeah.
Did we forget to finish something?
Oh, I guess it's New Game Plus and we didn't do...
No moon here anymore.
Aw.
That was fun, guys.
No way.
Yeah.
I told you the yellow women had a plan.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
I mean, that was faster than I thought it would be.
Yeah, I thought so.
Yeah.
This guy on YouTube only one hour.
We had all the information, okay?
That guy was cheating.
Yeah, yeah.
We figured it out as we went along.
So you never doubt our plan.
It was good.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I had a fun time with all of you guys today.
Yeah.
And also, like, when we first started the game, I did not ex...
I...
Honestly, I don't know what we just did.
Like, I...
I'm a little confused on the plot of the story.
Yeah, me too.
Me too.
What we did is played more than two hours so we could never return the game.
I know.
No, it was cool, though.
It was cool.
It was, yeah.
Maybe we'll add more to it.
Maybe we'll add a second moon, you know?
Oh, no.
Oh, the DLC.
Some of those bosses, I never want to see again.
I think I'm good.
Yeah.
The one that, like, just, like, punts us to the ground.
I know.
That guy is horrible.
Like, like, he always comes out of nowhere, too.
Like, we don't even know when he shows up.
Yeah.
I wish we could see the, like, a death count of who died the most.
Oh, I'm pretty sure someone in our chat can, like, do a compilation of that.
If anybody has time.
Yeah.
Me and Nimi are in sync.
We are.
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah, you guys are.
We should line up.
We should, like, line up on the edge of the building and do, like, a...
Oh!
A synced dance.
Oh, yeah!
That's so true, but which hands?
Which...
A Macarena?
The Macarena?
Yeah, which one is red.
Which number?
Let's do, like...
I'll stand right here, fine.
Wait, which number?
Which number?
Which way do we face?
Do we face...
Maybe in a line, like, yeah.
Like that?
Okay.
Someone has to tell us the number to do.
Which way...
Which way do we face?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Licking.
Alright, alright.
How about...
What number?
What dance?
Dance 2?
No, that's the chicken dance.
Wait, this looks so good!
Okay, okay.
We'll do a countdown.
Are you guys ready?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What dance 2?
It's dance 2, yeah.
Okay.
Wait, how do I...
Wait, hold on.
Oh, I gotta stop.
Okay, alright.
I'll do it on one, okay?
How do you stop?
Oh, you just have to move a little bit.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
3...
2...
1...
How are we in?
Like...
None of us...
How are none of us in sync at all?
1...
2...
Alright, switch to dance 8.
1...
3...
2...
1...
Oh, oh.
Ah!
Dancing!
We're in sync!
Okay.
Um...
Maybe not me, though.
It kind of works.
It's like a delay.
It's like on first.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
That's true, that's true.
I like this one.
You guys saw how everybody calls this green and yellow woman, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh, yeah.
Very creative.
Very, very creative.
This is good.
GG's, guys.
Woo!
What a journey.
GG's!
I think this was a mission success for us.
Yeah!
Damn.
I love these stupid horror games, so I'm always down.
Me too!
That's fun.
Kusoge.
I love it.
Me too.
Especially like...
Boy's Proximity.
Yeah!
Hey guys, can we do flip?
Alright.
Do a flip!
Three, two, one!
What?
Wait, what is F?
What's F?
Oh!
It's the new.
Whenever someone dies, I'll be sure of them died!
I can't remember.
I didn't even see it.
Every time someone dies, we could've all been around their body.
That flip was awesome!
That was a pretty cool flip.
Someone should make a montage of just that flip.
With different perspectives.
You know?
GG's, guys.
I had a great time with all of you.
With my green and yellow one.
Yeah!
GG's.
Until like...
I hope we get to play something again.
Yeah!
GG's, guys.
I guess we'll all talk to our chat now.
Okay!
Bye-bye!
The entire server closes.
Wait, I wanna see if I can die by this thing.
Oh, okay.
I guess we can F her.
Kill me!
You can still die.
Oh.
Yay!
Okay.
I'm going to...
Leave the Discord...
Call...
I have to remember to turn their volume up, though.
Wait!
Was the moon always in the sky?
At the menu?
Or did we do that?
Yeah, the moon is up there now!
Oh, so fun!
I'm kind of curious, though.
What else is...
What else do you do...
At...
The end.
You know?
Because it's...
They were like, oh...
What did you forget to do here?
Nothing?
I don't know.
Bring back my girl?
Hmm...
No?
There's nothing else?
Maybe just explore the map?
But you can still die!
I don't wanna just explore the map...
Where there's so many things coming at me, no?
In case you didn't do the orange head quest...
Maybe.
Oh, some Easter eggs!
That's true, that's true, that's true.
That's true.
Yay!
That was so fun!
It was a bit of a short day.
I hope you guys don't mind.
But my throat is really hurting me.
So, I think I'm gonna take it easy.
Oh wait, hold on.
Let me get a mint, actually.
I have some...
Nodoame tablet.
This is a honey lemon.
Oh yeah, we didn't collect the books, that's so true.
Hmm.
So I guess if you're going after...
Oh wait, I wanna see, I'm curious.
I'm gonna go see what the achievements are on Steam.
Um, what is this?
Emissary.
Zero.
There was more...
Story to it than I...
Imagine, you know?
I thought it was gonna be like one of those...
Uh, like, repo, or something like that kind of games.
But no, it actually...
It actually was a thing.
Wait.
Oh, okay, here we go.
Wait, I'm confused.
What...
Which ones did I get?
Okay, so there's...
Meow?
What is meow, I wonder?
Supremacy of the black liquid.
Collect all Easter eggs.
Complete the quest of the smiling...
TV head.
You guys, only 0.1% of players...
Gets the...
Smiling TV head.
Achievement.
And then orange shards.
I don't know what that one is.
Yeah, there was one, two, three, four, five, six...
Achievements we didn't get.
Collect all the map fragments.
Collect all the special items.
What is the black liquid?
And then meow.
There's something...
There's an achievement with the cat.
We missed it.
Sad.
I wouldn't call it a story.
Well...
There was a...
Kind of a...
You know what I meant.
Maybe.
There was more of a narrative than not.
More than repo.
Yeah.
Right.
Black liquid, some sort of Death Stranding reference.
Mayhaps.
But that was so fun.
I'm glad Nimi also said that she likes these types of games.
Because...
I love these types of games.
So...
I would be happy to play...
With her and of course...
Tokidubi.
I like our little team.
It was a lot of fun.
Yeah.
The proximity voice.
Yeah, so good.
Hehehe.
It was a coherent weirdness.
Thanks for the month's dream.
Hope you feel better.
Don't be afraid to cancel or remove tomorrow's dream.
I think tomorrow's dream won't be so long.
Um...
Because I think Kirby is actually quite sh...
The first Kirby is quite short.
So...
I anticipated it on not being super duper long.
Kinda just taking it easy.
With uh...
With...
With um...
I guess today and tomorrow.
Because...
Today was pretty short too.
Hehehe.
Are you planning on doing Kirby series?
Yeah!
I wanna play...
I wanna play more Kirby's.
I want to.
I want to play...
So I was just like...
I want to try Kirby's.
So I will start at the first.
Hehehe.
So...
Yay!
Kirby Friday.
Whoops!
Saturday night.
Hehehe.
Mm-mm.
The silhouette is giving me some...
Digicarrot vibes.
Right!
When somebody pointed that out, I was like...
Wait, I'm...
I should finish all my sentences with Nyo.
Puchiko Nyo.
Actually, I own...
You know how like...
Well, maybe...
You don't know.
A long long time ago...
When Digicarrot...
Was like...
Came...
Was localized...
In the US.
They released like...
The hats.
And I had both of them.
I have both of them.
Yeah...
I think I still have...
My Dejiko one around.
Nyo.
Wait...
Did Puchiko say Nyo?
Now wait, this is gonna bother me.
Wait...
She said Nyo!
And then Dejiko said Nyo.
She says...
Puchiko says Nyo.
Oh my gosh.
I'm a fake fan.
This was good though.
This was a lot of fun.
Hope you guys had fun.
It was interesting.
For sure.
To say the least.
They were gaming.
The yellow women were gaming.
But...
I gamed a little bit today too.
I had some crazy jukes, no?
I had some crazy jukes today.
But...
I'll be honest.
I was so...
They were like...
We gotta go put the electrical board here!
I'm glad they remembered.
Because I was like...
Huh?
Whole.
Plot armor.
You had the password song.
If only I had the ability to put in the password.
That was good.
It was fun.
I was lost and I had no idea what the objectives...
The objectives were always in this left...
Top left corner.
But it would be like...
Go to this place!
And I'm like...
Where is that place?
Five...
One...
Two...
Five...
One...
Two...
You know what was crazy too?
Is that even works.
Like the song actually helped.
Yeah, the map was an absolute lifesaver.
Someone told me...
I'm so sorry to the person...
That said...
Hey, you should press the tab in chat.
And I was like...
No, I'm pretty sure I tried that last time.
I...
I don't know.
I could have sworn I tried it before.
But clearly I didn't.
So thank you.
Yeah...
Reminds me of Sunny's song from MGS.
Da da da...
Ooh...
Ah...
Music is always the answer.
So true.
There's an opera in my heart.
And I just...
I just always...
I just gotta let it out sometimes.
I am so...
Well guys!
Thank you, for more Emissary Zero.
Thanks for hanging out.
I hope you guys have a great weekend.
If I see you tomorrow for Kirby, I'll see you.
Um, enjoy, get some rest on your Friday.
And... I don't know what else to say.
No!
See you tomorrow!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Teeheehee!
Perfect start to the weekend?
Ah!
Um, I got some... I got a little bit of...
Work to do.
Been a lot of like, clean up...
Um, contacting artists and stuff that I was working with.
To continue working on stuff, so...
Um...
Trying to keep moving things in the pipeline, if possible.
Hmm...
So...
You, you, you!
A maid's job is never done.
Hehehehe...
Yeah!
Very cool.
Hmm...
Good luck with work!
Thank you!
Yeah, we're, we're, um...
We're making it work!
For all good!
Yeah!
It ain't easy being green!
I almost said greasy!
Like cheesy!
And green combined!
It ain't easy being greasy!
Hehehehe!
Okay, thank you guys.
Thank you.
I appreciate you guys so much.
Have a good rest of your night.
Take it easy.
Oh no, I can't show you guys that.
I did see a preview for something that should be coming out soon and it looks really good.
I can tell you that at least.
It looks so good.
Probably isn't easy being greasy either.
It's so true.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh.
No.
I was going to say something, but I think... I don't need... I think I'm still trying to decide what to do.
There were some things that I, like, was getting done.
But obviously, if debut was not happening anymore, I was like, oh, well...
Maybe I'll just kind of roll stuff out as it comes.
But I'm still trying to decide what to do.
Sorry, that's so, like...
It's my own brain at work.
I'm thinking out loud.
Okay, sorry.
Okay, anyway.
Bye-bye.
See you guys later.
Thank you so much for watching.
Thanks for hanging out.
Bye-bye.